this person is saying i am
currently studying the sanctuary
what is the sinner's responsibility
when approaching the sanctuary
what are the steps well the steps are very
simple let's go to leviticus chapter one
leviticus one we read from verse one now we
will look at the most fundamental sacrifice
in the bible it was the first to be offered and
for hundreds of years it was the only sacrifice
offered from abel all the way down to to abraham
it is called the burnt offering remember paul says
i beseech you therefore brethren by the mercies
of god that represent your body's living sacrifice
holy acceptable unto god this is a burnt offering
it was the offering in which all the sacrifice was
consumed on the altar leviticus 1 from verse 1 and
the lord god called unto moses and spake unto him
out of the tabernacle of the congregation saying
speak unto the children of israel and say unto
them if any man if you bring an offering to the
lord you shall bring your offering of the cattle
even of the herd and of the flock if his offering
be a burnt sacrifice of the herd let him offer a
male without blemish he shall offer it of his own
voluntary will at the door of the tabernacle of
the congregation before the lord verse 4 and he
shall put his hand upon the head of the burnt
offering and it shall be accepted for him to make
a tournament for him verse 5 and he shall kill
the bullock before the lord and the priest aaron's
shall shall bring the blood and sprinkle the blood
round about upon the altar that is by the door of
the tabernacle of the congregation and he shall
flee the burnt offering and cut it into his pieces
and the sons of aaron depression put fire upon
the altar and lay the word in order on the fire
now we have a division of labor in that passage
what do i mean by division of labor there are
two people identified in that drama who are they
the priest and the sinner chiefly
the sinner brings the animal
the sinner has to be sure it has no spots when
he brings it and of course the priest also checks
verse 4 says and he shall lay his hand
upon the head of the burnt offering
and it shall be accepted for him he puts
his hand to kill it the priest accepts it
christ accepts our sacrifice god accepts christ
as a sacrifice for us the man the sinner is
the one who puts his hand meaning he kills it
patriots and prophets page 68 paragraph one as
adam slew the innocent victim he trembled at the
thought that his sin must shed the blood of the
spotless lamb of god the sinner there are some
adversaries who believe the priest killed the
animal the sinner kills the animal the sin has to
understand the horrible nature of sin the sinner
kills the animal and solely vegas 1 4 and 1 4
he shall put his hand upon the head of the burnt
offering and it shall be accepted for him by the
priest to make atonement for him he can't make
the atonement it's made for him but he brings the
sacrifice in verse six and he shall flee the burnt
offering and cut it into his pieces the sin it did
that now many hundreds of years later the priest
would do it because when the israelites were
settled in canaan so many thousands of sacrifices
were offering a day you couldn't have the people
doing the flame the levites would do it but in
the wilderness and prior to that the sinner flayed
or removed the skin and cut the thing into pieces
and it was washed and then reassembled on the
altar in the same shape as the animal itself yes
that's confession of sin yes and that's
what we learned in leviticus 16 verse 20
and aaron shall lay his hand upon the head of the
burnt offering and shalt he shall transfer confess
the sins of the children of israel and
all the transgressions and all these sins
it is a ceremonial transfer of sin to that
spotless animal which by the way still remains
spotless even after the sins we transferred
because we must have a spotless sacrifice
christ carries our sins and yet remains sinless
tremendous mystery thank you very much for that uh
since we're on the topic um on the lines
of that sure the center had a role to play
that's the way salvation works cooperation
there must be cooperation between god and man
the sinner brings the animal kills the animal cuts
the animal in pieces the priest catches the blood
the priest accepts it as a as a a sin a spotless
animal the presuppose the blood the priest does
that they both have their part to play i confess
jesus to have forgives because that literal animal
is not jesus you understand it's not jesus it
pointed the mind just as the serpent on the
brazen serpent in the numbers 21 was not jesus but
it represented christ who brought the sins of the
world when they looked to that in faith looking
to christ they were healed of the slave bite amen
you